informando la verdad,
mi mensaje es que sabemos que
viajaré
con decenas de miles que llegan cada
día
y donde las tropas rusas han estado
ocupando territorio en contra de la voluntad de
la gente
y luego iré a los
países bálticos a letonia lituania
que enfrentan una amenaza renovada de la
propia rusia
sobre las antiguas repúblicas soviéticas
lafayette lituania estonia son nuestros aliados de la otan
reafirman la soberanía y la
integridad territorial de ucrania
y condenan las invasiones de rusia
es
de otro país soberano por la fuerza
para reemplazar su voluntad
insistiendo en el pueblo ucraniano
en el cairo 241 miembros
naciones unidas
para las personas de todo el mundo durante casi
80 años
esta vez